[Music]
that's between 60 million and 240
million people now in light of that
shocking statistic as well as the deadly
Terror attacks in San Bernardino do
authorities need to start surveilling
mosque here in the United States to see
if they have connections to extremist
groups joining us now with reaction
author of the complete infidels guide to
Isis Jihad watch's director Robert
Spencer act for America founder Bri
Gabriel as well as Dr Nadal alad and he
claims he was forced to resign
as an Imam from the Islamic complex of
Triplex after he appeared on this show
earlier this week and supported Donald
Trump's proposed Muslim ban temporary
ban now since yesterday we have tried to
contact the Islamic Society of Triplex
to get a statement or here their side of
the story but they have not gotten back
to us Imam let's start with you so you
come on the show you say you support the
idea of a temporary ban so we can get
our vetting system right what
happened it's that's exactly right
the problem is
I day after day it's becoming more clear
to me that a lot of American Muslims
that's what we have been explaining for
in many lectures we do to the youth a
lot of American Muslims it seems like
they have no
tolerance for they are ready to fight
they are ready to attack I've been
receiving since your show over about six
or seven text messages threatening me
for how how dare about banning
immigrants and Muslims those people
that's what we have the problem to
especially after being forced to resign
yesterday through some messages from
some people what's the reason they gave
that you were forced to resign what did
what did they tell you his his exact
statements how how possible that you
could support Trump and you know who is
Trump what is what do you mean like I
know who's Trump we are dealing with
facts and we're dealing with certain
statements we religious people and
leaders go with a textbook we with
original Don't Take Em in our viewpoints
we don't take presidential candidates
they have their own campaigning why
would you mix a a campaign with a
message that will bring peace to us see
that's the isue let me ask you this were
those death threats that you got and
were they from people in your mosque or
from around the country it's mostly in
boom I've seen numbers coming on and
some other you know numbers are I
believe it's within the boom uh greater
you know origin area it's it's not I
don't think it's out
bom
Houston problem I also received that
over over 102 imams in Houston were also
terminated this week also due to some
differences in viewpoints they give we
have trouble here with American Muslims
across the United States in all these
hundreds of Islamic societies they are
basically not doing doing zero job in
trying to educate the youth about take
to live as a peaceful American Muslims
in this country let me let me go to Brit
Brit because we have been saying we want
moderate Muslims in this case you're
talking about a leader an Imam to speak
out against those that hijack this
religion and use it to kill innocent men
women and children he to me is is part
of the solution but yet he's rejected
and thrown out of his mosque and now
he's getting death threats or getting
threats from people what does that tell
us uh this is a reality check this is a
reality check for everybody who says we
need to reach out uh we need to uh uh
work with the moderate Muslims the
majority of them are moderate and here
when you see someone an Imam like him
who actually really steps out and says
listen we have a problem we need to
start educating the youth about moving
away from radicalism you see the
reaction that he is getting and he's not
the exception we have heard this
reaction Sean towards people who spoke
up before likei Hamid and Zi jasser and
many of the moderate Muslims that we
work with and what we need to pay
attention to is the radicalization of
American mosques in America today you
know three separate studies done between
2005 and 2010 of American mosques across
the United States and some of the most
prominent mosques in America showed that
70% of American mosques are radicalized
and what happened to this Imam is just a
reality check for us to learn from yeah
and Robert Spencer I mean you know I
we've always said to win this battle we
need moderates we need Muslims to stand
up against radicals in their religion
here you have the courageously saying
you know what for the safety of the
American people the vetting system isn't
right we now know that they're forging
passports syrians are Syrian passports
Isis is Isis has a plan to infiltrate
the refugee community and this amam says
no no the safety of Americans comes
first let's get that right and he's
thrown out of his mque I'm trying to
understand it's very telling Sean what
does it tell you it's very telling
because what you have here is the fact
that Isis and other Islamic groups like
it they claim to be the exponents of
authentic Islam and they threaten to
murder as apostates and Heretics anybody
who gets out of line so if you are a
genuine moderate a sincere Muslim who
actually rejects the idea of Killing In
The Name of Allah and Muhammad then
you're putting your own life on the line
and you could well be threatened this is
why one of the reasons why we don't see
a big push back among moderates and why
it's foolish to count on them the there
have been Muslims against Isis rallies
that have gotten like 30 people 50
people here and there around the country
and it they don't have the huge numbers
you see for people like protesting
cartoons of Muhammad and things like
that the problem that we have is that
the Islamic jihadists can point to the
texts and teachings of the Quran and the
example of Muhammad to justify their
actions moderates have no counter to
that well let me ask you Mom let me ask
you you heard Loretta Sanchez a
democratic congresswoman saying that she
believes it's between 5 and 20% of the
population that has been radicalized you
you know through your own experience do
you do you think those numbers are
correct even if it wasn't correct Sean
even one percent is too much to tell you
the truth so if if that's happening on
American soil of the Contemporary like
level of Life they were living like
right here with all kind of Freedom all
types of open opinions to discuss and be
diff different learning even the laws of
differences people are getting there
there's an inherent violence that is
been basically built in many of these
Muslims I sadly you know to say that
because because I've seen it I'm I'm
their Imam they're praying behind me do
you their religious leaders do you feel
your life is in Jeopardy
sir after I've seen all these messages a
lot of people are advising me to contact
the authorities and FBI and it seems
like this is going to happen soon yeah I
would do that I think that makes sense
all right thank you all for being with
us very sad